today I want to speak to you about why
quarter-million-dollar your income is
the new six figures I'm Patrick beta via
host of ie10 weekly and I want to talk
to you about that magical six figure
number that was a big deal in the 80s
with Bank Rate I had the link on the
bottom set in the 80s if you made six
figures you drove a 7 Series BMW lived
in a beautiful lavish home and you went
to nice restaurants life was good and
today making six figures means you're
living a fifty and underscore foot home
and you drive a seven year Toyota
Corollas what it's saying right today
not obviously in an example but you
think about it coming out of high school
coming out of college when we don't have
a lot of expenses yet we're not married
we don't have kids we don't have a
mortgage we haven't bought diapers yet
to know how much it cost we don't know
how much life costs right and then you
graduated from college and you have
payments you got to make to school all
this other stuff you reality really sets
in on how much life is going to cost but
everybody who comes out most people want
to strive to get that six-figure income
I want to give you some numbers that
shows you what six figures in 1980 means
today just to share some numbers with
you that I got from the US Census Bureau
here's some of the numbers in 1980 if
you bought a stamp it cost you 15 cents
today's 49 says that's an increase of
two hundred and twenty six percent dozen
eggs forty eight cents today $2 increase
of three hundred and sixteen percent
bacon listen to bacon a buck 20 I know a
lot of people love bacon today bacon is
six dollars and 11 cents that's an
increase of 409 percent a house to buy a
house in 1980 the average house
according to US Census Bureau was
sixty-two thousand nine hundred dollars
you know what the average house is today
two hundred and eighty thousand nine
hundred dollars that's an increase of
346 percent is what we're talking about
to buy a house same exact size house
average income in 1980 was seventeen
thousand seven ten today the average
income is fifty-three thousand eight
ninety one an increase of two hundred
and four percent
so if we go based on these numbers that
were sharing $100,000 your income in
1980 today is a $400,000 or your income
$400,000 your income to be able to
afford the luxuries of all of these
numbers that are increase on a minimum
of 200% me give you some more numbers
here six figures used to be a big deal
because only 2 to 3 percent of people
used to make $100,000 in the 80s today
according to the Census Bureau 22% of
Americans households make over $100,000
a year income only 2% makes over a
quarter million dollars our president
wants to tax people over a quarter
million dollar income because he
considers that a rich family somebody
that's making good money a quarter
million dollar your income it's only 2%
see life is getting more expensive
according to US Department of
Agriculture do you know what it takes
for a parent a husband and wife to raise
a kid from the day they're born to 18
years old not including college you know
how much it costs two hundred and forty
five thousand three hundred and forty
dollars per child per child if you have
to that's a half a million dollars if
you have three that's three quarters of
a million dollars is what we're talking
about and someone's listening to this
and saying how are people even making it
well that's the real question
how are people making it with six
figures how are people even doing it
with $150,000 your income now you may
say well quarter-million dollars not
even a big deal in places like New York
you know LA or Chicago I would agree
with you but I'm generally giving you a
number on a quarter million dollar flat
out across the board that's the new six
figures so if you're watching the same
well how am I going to be making a
quarter million dollar your income at my
job I make 73 you know my my my spouse
makes 38 you know we make 111 thousand
dollars a year between the both of us
and we have two degrees and I'm paying
seventy three thousand dollars on my
degree and she's paying sixty eight
thousand dollars on her degree we're
making all these payments we're making
the Sally makes this by the way this is
real life we're concerned about having
kids maybe we don't want to have more
than
on cue because if we have one kid only
so we can at least take care because
what's a nanny gonna cost what's this
going to cost what's that gonna cost
cost of living is going up so you're
asking a question great all of this
sounds good
how do I make a quarter-million dollar
your income household well if you
generally look at what industries pay
quarter million dollars if you google it
you can look at it for yourself have a
couple links on the bottom for you to
look at typically medicine money
industry and computers medicine money
industry and computer software things
like that medicine you got to go for 12
years to be around the quarter mil
quarter million dollar income which
means another three four hundred
thousand dollars of that money you just
need some licenses to get into whether
it's real estate financial insurance
it doesn't matter money industry then
you have the computer programmer which
you may need to have a software and
engineer eight years go to certain
schools to do that these are things that
you ought to ask yourself because the
true alternative on why immigrants like
myself why America still leads all
countries in the world for having 40
plus million immigrants that come to
America is because of the free
enterprise system because you and I with
or without a degree we can go out there
and start a business be an entrepreneur
based on our pure efforts make the kind
of an income we want to make if you need
to make a quarter-million dollar your
income you can make a
quarter-million-dollar your income it
doesn't matter as an entrepreneur you
control your income but my challenge to
you would be you know if you're watching
this video maybe you're watching with
your spouse maybe gonna replay this for
your spouse to watch it maybe gonna have
your kids watching your mom and dad
watch it your friends why are you gonna
share it with somebody but I would tell
you this my challenge to you would be
have an action plan to go over a quarter
million dollar your income I would have
that in place and for some of you that
are watching saying life is not all
about money I don't know if you have
kids
I don't know if you race kids I don't
know if you not much diapers cost I
don't know if you know how much food
costs for kids and how much private
school is our you know sending them to
get a nanny or having somebody take care
of babysitting or clothes and then
getting sick and going to the doctor and
health care and car payment car
insurance you know debts and you know
parties and birthday events and all
these
birthdays you're invited to all these
weddings you're invited to you know all
these gas miles driving food utilities
phones internet cable electricity you're
starting to get a trend of it that's
real life and I think if we really want
to make America pay off our 80 trillion
dollars of unpaid debt which is our 18
trillion dollars of national debt that
we have
then our commitments that we have for
Medicare Social Security Obamacare all
this other stuff there's only one place
government gets money from government
that doesn't make any money outside of
from private sector who creates money
for them to do programs such as build
roads public schools etc etc if we
really want to help pay off the debt for
our country which is a country we
represent we all need to pay a portion
of that to cut it down for all of us
we'd love to have our national debt be
zero because that's our credit as a
country I believe we all need to make an
effort to make more income and if we
want to have a better income for our
life quarter million is the new
six-figure a year income so my message
in the week to I would love to hear from
you please be sure to share this video
with other people who may need to watch
it as well as subscribe to the channel
thanks for watching action
let's have you
yeah I'm faster better in your host
evaluate a man weekly and today is one
of i/o average house medium house to buy
an average